[Musique]
l'alerte est donnée au milieu de la nuit
les sirènes résonneront jusqu'à l'aube
dans le ciel de Kiev selon le chef de
l'administration militaire local des
missiles calibres ont été détectés
depuis la mer Noire mais aucune
infrastructure n'a été touchée en
revanche à audessa dans le sud du pays
les dégâts sont considérables après une
attaque au drone explosif et homicile
plusieurs sites du port se sont embrasés
60000 tonnes de céréales ont été
détruites selon le ministre ukrainien de
l'agriculture des réservoirs ont
également été endommagés ces sites ont
délibérément été pris pour cibles par
Moscou selon le président zellenski la
région d'Odessa abrite les trois pores
par lesquels l'Ukraine exportait ses
céréales mais la Corse elle est avec
Moscou il y a plus d'un an n'a pas été
reconduit par les Russes le président
Zelinski avait alors prévenu qu'il
continuerait même seul d'acheminer le
grain le Kremlin réagit et rappeler
qu'il n'y avait plus de garantie de
sécurité après l'expiration de cet
accord les frappes ont aussi viser cette
zone résidentielle les habitants de cet
immeuble ont échappé au pire
heureusement je ne dormais pas j'habite
au premier étage j'ai vu un éclair rouge
à la fenêtre et j'ai réagi immédiatement
au moment où je suis tombé par terre
derrière le lit toutes les fenêtres ont
été soufflées je suis descendu il y
avait du bruit et de la fumée à
l'extérieur et Jean était paniqués
le lit se trouve juste à côté de la
fenêtre lorsque je suis entré dans la
chambre pour voir ce qu'il s'était passé
j'ai vu des éclats de verre sur les
oreillers et le matelas en Crimée akirof
c'est une installation militaire russe
qui a été frappée attaque confirmé par
le chef proclamé de la région plus de
2000 personnes ont dû être évacuées du
district